And everybody, welcome to another Zoom call, and let's just jump right into it.
So, and before I forget, happy Easter, this will be weekend, hopefully you're all going to have a wonderful family time and celebrating the reason why we're here, right?
Okay, first, announcements, remember to look at the announcements of the home page.
Remember site book.
We were downstairs this week, but look for them.
Let's jump right into the questions. Okay, first questions.
First question is, should cancer patients be gluten-free?
No, I wouldn't say so. No.
Is gluten, maybe another question for this would be, is gluten a driver for most cancers? No, it's very, very few cancers.
I mean, are there any cancers that serve feed off of gluten?
However, gluten is a laboratory for a lot of people. A lot of people have gluten sense.
Timmies, and would never know unless they did a gluten antibody on lab tests, which would be the Syrex array 3X.
And then possibly a Syrex array for to see if any cross reactants to that.
Now, that doesn't mean that if it let's say a cancer patient did a Syrex array 3X, they have antibodies to gliated peptide.
So, gliated is the is the protein and gluten that people have issues with.
And as it breaks down into smaller particles of amino acid products, which are called peptides before it gets down to the individual amino acid.
You can have, you can develop antibodies against those peptides. And then every time you eat gluten, it causes inflammation. Now, how would that relate to cancer?
You know, there are a few people that I tell to stay off of gluten or to limit gluten.
But it's mainly because of the testing that it came up as an issue with the cancer. And it's most likely it's because it's inflammatory.
So if the person does have peptides and they let's say they show up in the cheek swab test as they should stay off of gluten.
And I've listed that in a food that you should eliminate with your particular protocol.
And speak it's most likely because it's inflammatory to you and it's causing issues.
If we would do the Syrex 3X, it would probably be positive. We probably have positive antibody peptides to come and antibodies to differently added peptides.
So that's why should all cancer patients be gluten free? Again, I wouldn't say so.
Should everybody limit gluten, even if they, if they have cancer, it would be a good idea.
And again, the reason is is that it's inflammatory. We don't need any extra, you know, daily inflammation.
You can, the more daily inflammation that you can get rid of, the better off you're going to be for your cancer, the better off you're going to be for your whole body, the better off you're going to be for your brain health big time.
So just so you know, if you have any brain health issues, just about all the proteins that you could have antibodies against in the brain, like myelin sheath proteins or different proteins that would be a precursor for dementia or Alzheimer's issues or Parkinson's issues or any demilinated diseases.
And they all are molecular mimics to gluten, pretty much most of them are molecular mimics to gluten.
So you really cannot be on gluten. If you have any brain fog issues, dementia issues, you really should limit gluten.
If you have any emotional issues, let's say OCD issues or anxiety issues or depression issues, you really should be off of gluten.
If you have any thyroid issues, you should absolutely be off of gluten because for the added and it's peptides are molecular mimics to the thyroid plan. So there's a lot of reasons why people should not be eating gluten.
But you can't say that all cancer patients absolutely have to be on gluten, who did is almost never a feeder of the cancer. It's the inflammatory issues with gluten that we have toward the next question.
Is there an oatmeal that is good for you?
Well, I wouldn't say any oatmeal is bad for you, except what you really have to be careful with oatmeal is okay going back to the gluten issue.
All oatmeal is going to be cross contaminated with gluten, unless it says it's gluten-free oatmeal.
So because oats and wheat are typically stored in the same storehouses, you're going to have cross contamination on gluten to oatmeal.
So technically oatmeal has gluten in it, but it's going to be cross contaminated.
Secondly, oatmeal, unless it says organic, is definitely going to be filled with glyphosate.
So you should not be eating any non-organic oatmeal.
So if you're staying off of gluten, you should be eating gluten-free organic oatmeal.
You should not be eating non-organic oatmeal because it is definitely going to be related with glyphosate.
And glyphosate is definitely a driver of cancer.
So if it's organic and it's gluten-free, then by all means there's anything wrong with oatmeal.
The other issue that you could have with, well, should everybody just be eating organic gluten-free oatmeal?
Well, no, it's also got carbohydrate, so if you're trying to keep your glucose levels down, then you shouldn't be just eating the whole bunch of oatmeal.
You have to address that.
Now, if a person has got low to average weight, or if a person is in cakexia, be they're losing weight on a weekly basis,
then oatmeal is one of the things that I recommend.
But again, it's organic oatmeal that you're looking for, so it doesn't have glyphosate in it.
Next question. How can we manage daily pain without having to take Tylenol or leave for Advil or any over the counter?
Artica cream helps a little, but what else might be helpful?
So we've addressed this because pain can be an issue with people with cancer, right?
So how do you address pain from a natural perspective?
Well, there are things like artica creams. There are artica things that you could take poorly.
You could take artica as an herb poorly, or you could take artica folio path poorly.
Now, they tend to be helpful with minor pain issues.
Also, you can think of anything that's not, that is an anti-inflammatory, like your flavonoids.
Like the curcumid, the Vazwalia, the resveratrol, the EGCG from green tea extract, the white willow bark, any of the other barks, of course it is.
Those can be helpful, but again, mainly for more miter pain.
There isn't going to be anything from a natural perspective that's really going to work as quickly as a pain medication.
The only thing, the other thing that I would suggest is maybe thinking of the marijuana product, CBD really doesn't, isn't a pain reducer.
It can help with inflammation that's in the brain, maybe, but not elsewhere.
THC is the psychoactive form of marijuana, and that has been shown to be helpful with pain.
However, it has other side effects, not many people like feeling loopy, but it can help with pain at night because you're going to sleep anyhow.
Taking a THC product prior to sleep, maybe an hour before bed, it can help a person fall asleep, it can help a person stay asleep, and it can help a person stay asleep if they wake up because of pain, so it can help decrease pain and help a person get through the night.
Most people don't like to take the THC products during the day because you feel kind of loopy and out of it and nobody likes that I don't like to feel that way.
But from a natural perspective, there are a lot of things that are going to touch, pain like an un-steroidal anti-inflammatory or prescription medication, unfortunately.
What are the least invasive ways to monitor your cancer?
Of course, your oncologist, if you still have a relationship with your oncologist, is going to want to do scans, and while I love scans because you can see the most with them, they're not invasive.
So PET scan is going to be radiation, a CT scan is going to be radiation, an MRI is typically going to, you know, you got the magnetic field that can vest with your body, plus you're going to have gadolinium as a dye.
So, short of doing those things, what are some other ways to look at it, some people look at circulating tumor cells or cancer stem cells, there's a lab that does that.
Or you couldn't look at looking at running tumor markers, I think I just spoke to somebody this morning or maybe sometime this week about, they've never run tumor marker tests, they've never heard of tumor marker tests, go to our blog and just search tumor marker, you'll see it pops up, but I give you a whole display of different tumor marker tests that one can run for any particular cancer.
So, that's a way to monitor your cancer and then also just looking at standard blood work comprehensive metabolic panel and give us clues all tests are just giving us clues so these are objective things that we're talking about here first.
So, comprehensive metabolic panel you look at your liver marker you can liver markers you look at all the markers and if they're on a balance they can tell us and give us clues and things that are going on and that a complete blood cow to CBC said other standard blood test get one with a differential so that you can get a breakdown of the white blood cells and you can see it of course it has anemia anemia is very common with cancer.
So, if you have an anemia that can help monitor the cancer is stable or getting worse or whatever so that's another way inexpensive and least invasive ways to monitor your cancer.
And then from a subjective standpoint, how are you feeling or do you have the team do you have you know you go through different subjective things if you have a cancer that's palpable I can address cancer you feel like it's getting worse or bigger.
There's the things that you want to judge in this process and then you put them all together so you don't just look at one thing you look at all of them together to see give you clues on whether you're moving to the right direction or the wrong direction next question is there any reason a person should not take Ivermectin yeah there's a lot of reasons why a person should not take Ivermectin.
Understand, there's a few years ago we didn't hear about Ivermectin, haven't do this for what what he's six seven years taking care of people that have a cancer diagnosis all we never heard of Ivermectin.
We never heard of Ivermectin as all years ago and there was all sorts of you know talk about other things that you know were everybody had to do this or everybody had to do that I'm back in the early 2000s everybody had to do some go on a vegan raw food diet well that's just absolutely nonsense that you that that anybody should say everybody should blah blah blah.
For the most part. Yeah, everybody should eat better and stay away from toxins and everybody should stay away from sugar and
You know and and and get back to you know living the way God created us to live
But as far as like taking a medication that every cancer patient should take either of it and I just totally disagree with that
I don't think that unless your cancer is like growing like crazy. I don't think that you should just be throwing the kitchen sink it
Then I hear that phrase a lot like I just want to throw the kitchen sink it this and do everything
Well, there could be danger in that
Number one, you could overload your liver. You can damage your liver
You could damage your kidneys
you could
damage your cells because
Ivermectin and Mendezol are are drugs. They're they're toxins their medications that if they don't detoxify
They could damage your liver and could be stored in your cells and could be a source of other problems
Even herbal supplements taking too much of a good thing and be a bad thing
so I don't think you should
Take too much stuff, but I don't think you should do too many things all at the same time
You know if your cancer is stable and not growing then I don't think you should add Ivermectin or a fed bend is all
I think you should add things or change your protocol if your cancer is blowing the wrong way
So I'm a big fan of Ivermectin don't get me wrong and I'm a huge fan of fed Mendezol don't get me wrong
But certainly we do not have all of our patients slash members on any either one of those things and
If you're stable and doing well, I don't think you should add it just because you saw a
clip on
Instagram or or Facebook or something like that and then you feel guilty that you're not taking it you should do that
Don't don't make decisions that way. So
You know, that's what we're here for to test you that's what we're here for to answer these kind of questions
I don't think everybody should be on these things. It can these things can be toxic and though they're considered
It's quote-unquote safe medications. It doesn't mean they don't they're without side effects and it doesn't mean that they're without
Outdagers either so you have to be careful in doing any of those things
Now that I'm doing chemo, should I still take my fed Mendezol and CBD?
I would say yes, so you know, it's they're not
exclusive of one another just like
Okay, so let's say you start at an alternative path and you're using the ripe and doing herbs
Well, I'm doing chemo now. Should I stop taking the mushrooms? I stopped doing the ripe? Well, absolutely not
you know that it you know anything that you're gonna do that is going to help you you know, it's gonna be better if you're you know
If you're doing chemo doing all these other things are gonna be helpful. So no, and Mendezol is not
You know an issue with chemo. It's not an you know an antioxidant
Or you should have taken an antioxidant. I don't have anybody with an oxidant. It's really so it's there's nothing
Typically that you're taking if you if you started chemo that you really should stop taking
There are many ideas on how to sleep through the night. Well, it depends on
What the issue is so if you can't fall asleep at night then typically you think of taking
Somethings that won't call me your brain and
Stimulate melatonin or you take melatonin. There's different
Nutritional supplements out there that are that are calming to your brain and you know and will
Help you relax and fall asleep
But if your problem is I
Wake up in the middle of the night and then I can't go back to sleep
Well, are you waking up for a purpose? Are you waking up to go to the bathroom or are you waking up because of pain?
Whether you want to address those things or I wake up to go to the bathroom
But I used to be able to get back to sleep and I can't get back to sleep again
Then you have to think of cortisol issues and dealing with cortisol
Sometimes eating a protein before bed can be helpful for that
So eating a little piece of chicken before you go to bed can be helpful with that
Because you could get a cortisol drop at the middle of the night and then you can't get back to sleep
Unless you get up and walk around because your brain is basically starving for
For glucose and you burned all your glycogen stores
Or your cortisol level is low because you're stressed out and you don't break down the glycogen stores because you need cortisol to break down
The glycogen stores and you're liver to produce glucose at night to keep your brain alive
So you need a
level of glucose at night to keep your brain alive
So what a way you could test that if you really wanted to dig into it as you could test your glucose level and sleep at night
You could test your glucose level sometimes a person if that's the issue sometimes a person will show hypoglycemic in the middle of the night
Then you know eating something will help them fall asleep
Because they're they have that they have that circulated glucose
So there's different reasons for that if a person's not sleeping through the night
Like we talked about the other question because they have paid
Then you start thinking of using like a THC type product that could help them with the paid and help
Calm their brain and help them stay asleep. So there's so different you wanted like anything
You're trying to get to the reason why and fix that so
If if the problem of not sleeping through the day is because of pain, then I would think of
And if you're already you know why you have the pain then I would think of using like a THC product or something like that
If you can't fall asleep, I'd use something like an insomnetol or some other product with melatonin and other brain call me things
If you wake up at night, it's not because of pain. You can't fall back asleep. It could be a cortisol issue
So then you address that so and then what the cause is
Why is IP6 good for cancer patients? Well, I think I have some videos on IP6
But I think I have blog posts on IP6 and cancer as well
But IP6 has an ostital in it and that's a forum
It's actually a form of sugar
That helps
Helps the structure of yourselves and it helps with
It can help with brain issues and call me your brain again
That's you know, that's not specifically for cancer, but it can be extremely call me to the brain. It can be helpful for
People with panic attacks, anxiety issues, depression issues, OCD issues
IP6 is
Beneficial for cancer because it has immune stimulating properties that can help bring up your immune system can increase white blood cell production
Um, it has been showed in studies to
stimulate
extrinsic apoptosis
um, and
So it can help kill cancer cells directly
So IP6 is a good supplement time
A lot of people on it. It's one of those supplements that anybody
really could take
Um, and it's not it's not going to be something that's going to overwhelm your liver
Um, so that's
That's IP6
You said and I can see
That I have a defect on my medial gene so the medial genes are your vitamin D receptor genes
It doesn't always mean I should be taking more vitamin D
Um, no, so if you have
defects on your vdr genes
Then you have a greater propensity to
Have low vitamin D levels, but it doesn't always mean you do so I don't recommend
vitamin D usage
Based upon genetics
So you want to look at your blood test of your vitamin D levels
And if they're low, then we want to increase your vitamin D
Consumption so we did crease your
vitamin D um intake based upon your blood tests
However, when you look at somebody's genes that can tell you
Why you have low vitamin D levels I've had people with I can't figure out one of my vitamin D level
They're only 33 and I take
I use a vitamin D every day and I have for five years what the deal and I go and the sun and I get sun all the time
What's what's going on? Well you most probably tell that that person has vdr gene defects and without doing their genetics if that's the case
So it's but it does answer questions
So I don't recommend vitamin D based upon genetics we recommend vitamin D based upon your blood work
But it does answer questions. So why a person has low vitamin D levels
When they're taking vitamin D another reason why I personally have low vitamin D levels
And they're taking they've taken vitamin D their whole life
They may not they may have clean vdr genes
But they have an autoimmune disease many times autoimmune diseases can um
Increase the need for vitamin D
And the pleats vitamin D in the blood
Okay, next question. Should I send my labs I get to my from my oncologist to labs at cutters clinic.com
Yeah, so please if you get labs anywhere other than from us, please send them to labs at cutters clinic
Now come what's the best way to do this and act and should I make an appointment to go over them
Or just wait until you call me so the best way to do it is to download
your
the pf of the lab so
um
You download it as a pdf you save it as to your computer and then you
Send us an email and you'll attach that pdf to the email
If you don't know how to do that we could help you with that
Some people have given us access to their portals um layer like their medical portals
Were they're getting their labs test done or their lab core portals
That works great too
But then you we don't get notification that you did a lab so you're gonna have to
Notify us that you did a lab and it's in your portal now
So please don't notify us until it's in your portal because I'm not gonna remember
To to be located in your portal on a daily basis to see if your lab is there but once you get it in your portal
Um, and you've given us access to the portal you can do that now. There's some portals out there that don't allow us to save your
Access and we you have to get a pin to your phone each time well, that's just not gonna work
um
Most portals once you give us your user to pass word we can access it and we can pull that out
We could I could put that in your file here now should I make an appointment or just wait till you call me
No, the rule has always been you
You know you have to decide whether you want to go over your labs or not
Well, how do I know I don't know if their labs are bad or not well then just make an appointment um
But to do that because you know, I don't have time to look at everybody's labs and analyze them
You know and and then decide whether I want to talk to you know there's times that that's happened
So there's times that you know, I've been in communication with you as an individual and
And we're looking for something and I told you to get your labs or something and then you send me your labs
And I'm looking for and I tell Marie to call you and make an appointment. There's times that that's happened a lot of times
But lots of times um, I don't have time to do that
So if you want to make an appointment then you call us to make an appointment. So um
Don't rely on you know, be
Looking at your lab scene that something is wrong and then having to get back to you so um, you know make sure that
You know be on the lookout for your labs and tell us
If they have them make sure that we have your luggage your portal or download your PDF and send it to us and then
Schedule a appointment a lot of people send us labs
They have no desire to have an appointment with me. They're just sending it. They're regular labs on a
Multi-basis and um, so we are calling them to make appointments so
They don't want that
Okay, next question
If the Bible says that by his stripes, we are healed. Why do we still have cancer?
um
Because they're talking about a passage in the book of Isaiah that it says by his stripes
We are healed and that has been interpreted by some
Christian denominations
incorrectly that
well
Jesus died for our
Diseases and that he's going to heal all our diseases
And that Jesus healed everybody
well
That's that's not
corrected interpretation of that it doesn't say that
So it says by his stripes, we are healed
But does that mean that we're healed of our diseases or that by his stripes by his suffering and death and resurrection
Uh, here we're celebrating Easter this week by his suffering his death on the prophet is resurrection
We now have access to the Father so we have access to our heavenly Father through the new covenant because of what Jesus did
It doesn't mean that we are going to be healed of our all our diseases
Does Jesus does God still heal today? Of course he does
Let's be honest
And I am only breeding and speaking to you right now because the God's sustaining grace
That gives me the ability to be alive right now
So he has
In the process of keeping me alive right now for me to even be functioning
Without his sustaining grace on my life
I would already be dead
So he is doing that as he promised to heal all my diseases and to
cure all my problems and to give me financial
um, you know
And to buy me a Mercedes that's just God's sense and that is totally wrong interpretation of scripture usually manipulation in order to manipulate the
People to for some pastor to make a fortune off of something
And it's very incorrect and ungodly and um, that's not correct interpretation of scripture
Does God still heal today? Yes, he does
Did he heal at the did Jesus heal when he came here and he was
functioned living as a man on earth of course he did we can see that all the way through the gospels
Did the apostles heal were they given ability to heal people?
Yes, we can see that in the book of the accident apostles
Does Jesus heal that way today? Well, yes, he does and you can see testimonials of people that were healed
Miraculously um, you know their alcoholism their their sex addiction their cancer their diseases
But does God do that in that way all the time of course he doesn't
And we're all gonna die you know all the apostles died all our ancestors died
That what the healing that we receive through Christ that is promised if we surrender our life to him
He is the lord of our life
Through um
Through us surrendering to him is that we're healed for the kingdom of heaven today in order to be a blessing to be a witness
To have that relationship with him and for that future grace of being able to be in heaven and live forever and ever and ever with him
If that's a good enough for us
Then
We have something you know selfish and self-centered going on in our mind
I don't need to be healed of my cancer for God to prove who he is for me if I need anything
From God to prove who he is then you know
I already know I don't have a right relationship with him my relationship with him is surrender
That that and I allow circumstances in my life
Cancer and hardship and financial stress and family stress and relationship stress which we all have that's an all driver's
deeper to indeed to have that deeper relationship with him
um
That's the whole purpose of life our purpose in life is not to have you know health and wealth and prosperity and
Everything going perfect our purpose of life is to have that deep relationship with him
So we could go to him when we have troubles when we have struggles when we have paid
So that we allow our struggles to drive us deeper in that relationship with him so that we're more and more depended upon him on a daily basis
That's what my purpose in life is is did he come more depended upon him
Today than I was yesterday
and
We need to allow our struggles
Our ill hell our ill finances our ill relationships
To to do that work in us and
That's what living in the kingdom is
And salvation is not just for some future time to go to heaven salvation is for us to be in the kingdom now depended upon
God having a right relationship with our heavenly Father because of
Of Jesus Christ and through and only through Jesus Christ
We could have that
relationship with him
That we could communicate to him and pour out our struggles to him and he could comfort us
And we can climb up on his lap and we can be comforted by him and we could hear
um
Him say words to us that are that he loves us and he cares for us and
And
That's that's what we need that's what my purpose is is to have that deeper relationship today than a that what I had yesterday and I feel at that every day and
I just come back to it every day and I'm reminded through my struggles to come back to them
Okay, next question on the chat
It's been six months since my first micotoxin test and you recommend that you repeated it
Now I plan to retest this week should I be altering my supplements when I take this urine sample such as the key to clear
On no no unless it says it right in the test. I don't think you change anything that you're taking
um
For the micotoxin test. I don't believe so
Next question. Should I be doing the foot bath since I have a pacemaker now and I'm concerned about magnets
This person has the true right with the foot bath
Well, you could do the foot bath and that is not going to pacemaker is not going to be affected by that
The thing that you need to be careful with the pacemaker is not to do a ppw that so the rife is not
Contrindicative
To with someone having a pacemaker what is
Not recommended for someone having a pacemaker is electrical devices like um
You I mean you could still use the tens you could probably still use a rebuilder because you're putting it on your hands of your feet
Use a tens dot over the heart area dot over the chest
Um
Yeah, you that
You certainly wouldn't use a um to beat me about so I would have used a ppw if I had a pacemaker certainly would use it if I had it to
Next question I submitted this late this question late online. So ignore it later
I've been unbendman for about three weeks and the oncologist did a
CMP which is a comprehensive metabolic profile
add a cbc
Complete blood content Monday my ast went from 28 to 20 in my lt went from 24
To 13 of my alkaline phosphate went from 67 to 103
um
Now
Depending on what lab you use the lab normal and alkaline phosphates I've seen
As high as 125 is normal
The functional
normal for alkaline phosphates is up to 100
Um, but you're having a alkaline phosphates of 103
Is it because um
The bedbed is all I would say possibly but I wouldn't say that that's too high to take bedbed is all so what you really want to be careful
with
bedbed is all is
um
Is if the alkaline phosphates gets much higher than that
So I've had people with alkaline phosphates up to 150 and they still want to be on bedbed
Well, if it went from 75 to 150 in a month then
Then you'd go well, let's back off on it for a little bit and then go back on
There's other reasons why a person's alkaline phosphates would be elevated, obviously
So if your AST and ALT are within normal limits they both actually went down
But the alkaline phosphates went on that again remember all labs are giving us clues
Are there other things that could be going on well the next part of your question is my calcium went from 9.5 to 10.1
So if your calcium went up and your alkaline phosphates went up what's the most common thing
That that would be a clue for
Most common thing that would be a clue for is metastasis to bone
If you have metastasis to bone
It's going to cause destruction remember metastasis to bone is going to be lidic you could have ridic destruction of bone
And then that would also elevate calcium levels so it's spilling calcium into the bloodshed elevated blood calcium levels
But if the if a person has metastasis to bone
They would have spared the AST and ALT be they would have normal AST and ALT unless they had concurrent liver issues
It's a little complicated, but remember everything is a clue
So what I say you could stay on fed bed with blood tests like that
Absolutely, you should stay on fed bed with blood tests like that so
Absolutely, it's more likely that the alkaline phosphates
It elevation is from the metastasis to bone because of the calcium
Elevating as well and the AST and ALT actually going down
that it is
That the alkaline phosphates is elevated from the fed bed
And it's not high enough to
warrant going off the fed bed so I would say stay on
Rest of that question was my immature gradual site percentage was high
At 4.1
Which has never happened before the greater site number was high
Read about that number of cells
Bad that it's high and the nucleated red blood cell was 0.2 which is
High sensor rate is 0
Just wonder if these need
Anything due to the fed bed. No, I don't think they need anything
Due to the fed bed
Gradulate the immature gradual sites are precursors
For your gradual site
Type of white blood cell
That is gradual sites are ESIDophilus, Bayes of Philus in the neutrophilus
And that
Typically represents like an early response to an infection
Or
Response to inflammation
So
Elevated levels and B from a bacterial infection
And B from
Reaction to a medication too but I have not ever seen
That be elevated due to fed bed design but anything is possible right
They can also be elevated
With different cancers it can be elevated with
You know, love issues
You know, there's lots of different things that it
That it could go off with so it's something that
If I were you I would just I would run this test again in two weeks
I would so that was a question last week too. How often should I do my blood one?
Well, it depends if we're keeping an eye on something
This would be something we want to keep an eye on
So doing blood work weekly is not too often
So keep with you're keeping an eye on something that your that you
It things are awkward. We want to know why
Well, we need to run them again. Sometimes that's why if you go into the ER or something you're in the hospital
Why are they running blood tests on a daily basis because things can change quite quickly
And it's valuable to run blood tests on a daily basis. You know if a person is in a acute Bayes issue
so um
I I would run these at least at the far end within two weeks again just to make sure
Um, it just isn't something like an acute infection going on or something like that
Think of any other questions
All right, well, thank you for being on today and um
We will move back next week
So get your questions in there
And we'll talk to you really next week. Have a blessed day and have a wonderful Easter